financial freedom it's what everyone
wants the ability to not worry about
money the ability to flex on people and
also sit on a beach for some reason with
a laptop which i'm sorry is a dumb
fantasy sand and keyboards do not mix
all you've done is give yourself a
terrible experience with both sorry to
go on that weird tangent but also it
needed to be said the point is that
everyone wants financial freedom and
many people look to cryptocurrency as a
new way to get it because nobody trusts
the monopoly man controlling the money
printerino anymore and because of that a
lot of new people have been happy to
step in and promise to be the solution
the new monopoly man if you will but a
better one sort of inter
celsius who we're talking about today a
company that takes crypto and also lends
it that pitched itself as being a new
place to put your money and borrow money
but that's kind of not a bank it calls
itself a new economy an economy where
quote financial freedom doesn't come
with a price tag which sounds about as
believable as a diet pill that gets you
a six-pack without the exercise but even
so celsius's pitch was undeniably
effective promising up to 10 a year on
your money since they opened their doors
in 2017 they've taken in a grand
whopping total of 25 billion dollars
worth in crypto and for a while things
were going great right up until on june
12 2022 they suddenly collapsed without
warning and froze withdrawals and went
radio silent and it has everyone
wondering how could this happen well
that is what we are trying to answer
today i've done a shorter video on this
which we'll link here but this time
we're gonna go much deeper down the
rabbit hole because i believe celsius is
unfortunately
finished insolvent and i'm about to tell
you why it begins with one man and his
vision
you know
we need we need someone to help us with
our financial uh
accounts with our financial life
and normally we trust people that we
think are acting in our best interest
but what if these people are not acting
in our best interest what the banks
really think is that
because we have to trust them we cannot
trust somebody else so they they don't
believe that a company like celsius can
exist because who would be crazy enough
to give their coins their crypto to
somebody who's not a bank right that is
alex mashinsky the creator of celsius
he's critical to understanding the
collapse of celsius and the first thing
you should know about him is that he
claims to have done a lot in his career
we can get a glimpse of just how many
businesses alex has had in his lifetime
from a 1999 article which says this he
tried importing urea from russia selling
indonesian gold to switzerland and
brokering poisonous sodium cyanide
excavated from china for use by gold
mines in the us now all of these
businesses failed obviously but the
point is he's always been selling
something and probably the biggest thing
he's been selling is one of his claims
that says that he's the person who
invented voip voice over the internet
protocol something that i know you've
used before even if you've never heard
of it things like whatsapp use it but
this claim it turns out is actually a
little bit exaggerated alex mashinsky
says he's one of the inventors but all
the records i could find on the history
of voip suggest he wasn't the first to
do it or even a key inventor at all he
has a patent that goes back to 1994 but
voip was already a thing by then with an
app called rascal in 1989
and he wasn't the first to monetize it
either a company called vocaltech was
the first but as you'll find alex
doesn't let an inconvenient truth like
that stop him instead he pitches himself
as a central piece of this technology
despite most histories of voip not even
mentioning him and this is a pattern of
behavior of slightly stretching the
truth he claims in fact to be the
inventor of a lot of things he says he
has patents that cover aspects of the
smart grid ad exchanges twitter skype
the app store netflix's streaming
concept you'd think he basically
invented the internet actually and in
addition to him being this amazing
inventor another core part of his story
seems to be that he's also a man of the
people not interested in money but
instead he's interested in fighting for
the little guy and taking down mean old
monopolies this is his core pitch about
voip and also it's his new pitch today
about banks so i i fought the monopolies
my entire life i mean i fought the phone
companies i thought
all the different people who
uh thought that it was a god-given
right for them to charge high rates
forever to all of us
and and so voip was a great example of
that right where basically we created a
new technology a new platform completely
decentralized uh uh completely
autonomous to the phone through the
entire phone lines infrastructure
and it wrote on the internet for free
right so the same thing is happening now
with money right and the first time this
is the first time
that that you can basically replace the
banks the internet hasn't been able to
do it the first time that the technology
the crypto technology and the blockchain
technology can replace the banks
completely with peer-to-peer so we're
going from
voice of rfp to money over ip money over
ip he says that's his new project with
celsius and i gotta say moib has to be
the worst marketing term for something
of all time it sounds like a chronic
disease honestly most people instead
usually call it defy decentralized
finance where you cut out the middleman
and create smart contracts or little
bits of code to replace what a bank
might do like lending for example
instead of going to a bank you can go to
compound or ave to get a decentralized
loan but crucially in this defy world
celsius doesn't exactly actually fit
because it's not decentralized at all
it's just his company and this is where
things get a little weird because when
alex mashinsky describes what celsius is
in theory it sounds like he's
eliminating banks that is the killer the
application of basically eliminating the
toll collector
is the purpose of the blockchain but
then when he describes what celsius
actually does it sounds like
he is a bank so celsius network enables
you to deposit your coins it enables you
to lend them to someone else and you get
to keep 80 of the value i mean you just
heard it celsius takes deposits and
lends money that's literally the
definition of a bank according to
investopedia except well for the fact
that in this definition it also says
licensed and in that one sense the worst
since of all alex is correct celsius is
not a bank because it turns out they're
not licensed to do this if your bank
loses money for example it's insured if
celsius loses your money well
you're out of luck and this verbal
sleight of hand is a pattern with
celsius mashinsky would use words like
deposit and withdraw which sounds like
banking terms for a savings account
don't they but in their terms of service
they explicitly spell out that
these aren't banking terms at all it's
not what they mean instead celsius
considers these deposits actually a loan
to them that you are lending to them to
then lend to somebody else and when you
withdraw your money you're not
withdrawing from an account you own
you're calling your loan due basically
and it turns out that's a pretty big
difference the other big trick they did
was convincing people that like a
savings account they said their earn
program where you could get up to 10 a
year on your deposit they said it was
low risk incredibly low risk as seen in
this clip bitcoin is dividend price
elsewhere how does bitcoin point
because we earn yield
how do you earn yield on bitcoin what do
you do to generate income on that bill
i'm happy to spend an hour with you yeah
you're trading it you've got to be
taking tremendous amount of risk the
bitcoin itself doesn't generate any
yield
it does just like any other asset can
generate yield gold no but what earnings
what earnings does the bitcoin generate
gold generates five and a half percent
at celsius yield token what are you
doing to generate that you've got you've
got you must be taking tremendous risk
to generate those returns well that
turned out to be a huge lie they were
taking tremendous risk now i spoke with
a celsius insider who on the condition
of being anonymous told me that quote
they were kind of degenerate in their d5
pools so it turns out they were taking
tremendous risk according to their own
people and i also spoke with a crypto
sleuth called dirty bubble media who's
been tracing these actions a long time
before it fell apart to understand more
and i asked him how is it possible that
celsius could earn 10 percent or more on
their crypto here's what he told me
essentially they were engaging in some
fairly risky practices essentially
taking borrow borrowed assets and
lending on the multiple times in order
to try to maximize the yield and most of
most of their yield was likely coming
from stable coin loans at least their
claims are that they were making these
large loans of stable coins out to like
institutional traders who
were engaging in undescribed or
undisclosed activities that somehow
generated the return sufficiently high
enough to make these uh 10 or higher
payments one way i had heard it
described was that people thought they
were investing in a bank with celsius
but actually they were investing in more
like a hedge fund do you sort of agree
with that yeah i mean i think that
describing them as a hedge fund that was
playing with retail money is probably a
fairly charitable way to describe it but
they definitely weren't operating like a
bank so i know you looked at their d5
wallets what kind of returns did you see
them getting there did you see them
getting like 10 12 15
no not at all um so what they're what
part of their strategy was using d5 to
access stable coins so
for example they would borrow ether from
their customers they would then deposit
that borrowed ether into say a compound
uh d5 protocol and then use that as
collateral to then borrow stable coins
against and then from there the stable
coins flow out all over the place and
that's something that trying to track
that is very difficult um but
essentially i mean net that actually
costs them more money than it makes
because first they're paying interest
rates out to their customers to borrow
the ether and then they're also paying
uh
between two to three percent to those
protocols to borrow the stable coins and
over collateralized matter so
it was actually costing them money and
on the part of the the part that's
actually visible to us on the on the
blockchain so
they're making all these bets some of
them risky and i guess you found that
some of these didn't exactly pan out can
you explain that yeah so there were a
couple mistakes that they've made that i
found and there are probably others as
well
one example of that was this thing
called steakhound ether which to get
into it's a little bit complicated but
essentially they were using this service
to take some of the customer ethereum
and deposit it to this eth2 contract
which is something that has to do with
ethereum switching from proof of work to
proof of stake the long story short is
that the money that goes into this
contract is locked so you can't access
it for a very long period of time it's
indefinite at least until the switch
occurs
so what state count allowed you to do
was they gave you a derivative token
that you could then kind of keep playing
with and use to say borrow against or
lend out
and for a while the market was treating
that as equivalent to uh ether um the
problem was that state count actually
lost the keys to uh over half of the big
or the ethereum that or ether that they
had uh deposited so essentially what
happened is the crypto that they gave
them is locked up for essentially
forever unless the keys can be found and
the ste derivative token that they were
using to kind of
uh stand in for the for the ether that
they had deposited basically is
worthless now so that's it was a massive
loss i mean we were talking tens of
millions of dollars another example was
this badger dell hack which happened uh
several months ago um essentially it was
like a phishing attack they were
participating in this badger dow
protocol they ended up losing 54 million
dollars of rap bitcoin wow that's a lot
of money but there's also a side of this
which is the incompetence
of celsius which i think a lot of
customers didn't know about at the time
uh explain that
yeah so
badger dell in order to try to salvage
the situation
um came up with a plan essentially to
reimburse people and it's a little bit
convoluted but essentially the way it
worked was that the the dow gave
the the victims these tokens called rem
badger so reimbursement badger and the
only the only requirement was that they
had to hold those tokens in their wallet
or in the badger dell protocol for a
period of two years as the as these
rewards were paid out over time
unfortunately and i haven't got an
explanation as to why this happened but
a few months ago celsius actually
removed all those ben badger tokens from
that deposit account
and essentially that means they they
lost the right to get any more
reimbursements from the dow why did they
remove the the badger tokens i mean your
guess is as good as mine so it's
literally stupidity is what you're
saying it was the mistake well so it's
the the mistake is so egregious because
there was actually a warning screen that
would pop up and say you know if you do
this you are forfeiting all of your
reimbursements from here on out tens of
millions of dollars just lost because of
a stupid
basic mistake yes
see it's stories like this that appear
to be something of a microcosm for
celsius a small example that shows a
much deeper problem problems like
growing too quickly and having bad
executives see celsius by the time of
their collapse was almost at 800 people
mind you this is only like a four to
five year old company and just in the
past year statistics showed they grew
their staff by
281 percent you can just not on board
people this quickly they were growing
too fast and trying to scale too fast as
well and ultimately it looks like they
paid the price remember that this is
supposed to be a budget bank passing on
the savings to their customers unlike
you know the
big traditional finance banks but with
this many employees it's not clear how
that's even possible i mean they were
likely spending somewhere between
10 to maybe 50 million dollars per year
just on employees and again this might
not be a problem if they were hiring
star employees but the opposite actually
seems to be true when we dig into it
here are a few examples of what i mean
their chief financial officer for
example got actually arrested while
working for the company under money
laundering charges their chief revenue
officer also got in trouble when he
started a business with a convicted
money launderer while at the company and
then you also have their head of lending
a 24 year old whose face i will blur for
privacy who turns out to only really
have been in the industry for four years
before she worked as an adult actress
before coming onto celsius and then
moved into a marketing assistant
position before becoming the head of
managing hundreds of millions of dollars
of loans to have someone with only a few
years of experience handling hundreds of
millions of dollars of customers money
is just always going to be a bad thing
and once again the insider that i spoke
to at celsius agreed that this was all
sort of par for the course they called
it a quote story of incompetence that's
literally how they described this whole
company but of course you wouldn't know
about that would you if you just
listened to alex mashinsky who describes
his company in much different terms he
describes it as safe and of course
totally solvent only days before they
froze all their funds alex was still
going on amas saying stuff like this are
our funds safe at celsius can you
address that for the audience yes so not
just that they're safe again we
provided anyone who wanted to withdraw
partially or fully there were no
problems i know people are
uh concerned about the whole market and
they were specifically concerned with
the terra luna situation that we've
publicly stated many times
that we would we didn't lend to them we
were we didn't buy luna or ust we were
not
like many others who invested in the
project we didn't have any exposure to
that and not only was he saying
everything's fine he would frequently
get angry at people accusing his money
of not having all the dollars or just
asking questions for example when this
user said that he hopes retail investors
can get out alex responded mike do you
even know one person who has a problem
with drawing from celsius why spread fud
and misinformation if you are paid for
this then let everyone know you are
picking sides otherwise our job is to
fight tradfi together but it's not just
people on twitter they're going after
when this youtuber criticized celsius he
also got in trouble but this time
received a cease and desist letter from
them he joins me now upper echelon
gamers why do you think celsius was so
worried about the criticism you were
giving them and how vindicated do you
feel that you've basically been right
about them this whole time alex
mashinsky has a pretty long track record
in my opinion of making false
accusations or false statements and
right up until 24 hours before
they closed down all withdrawals he was
saying do you know even a single person
who can't get their money why are you
spreading fud fear uncertainty doubt
right this buzzword to discredit
criticism so yeah there is an element of
i guess there's a personal side to it
where i do feel a sense of ha gotcha you
know why would you send me a letter like
that why would you fixate hyperfixate on
one tiny portion of a video that in my
opinion highlighted very extreme things
that should be looked at by the
community pieces of information that are
not well known things that he's denied
in amas such as
pretending he doesn't know who moshi
hoage is and yet he was an advisor to
moshi hog's syrian labs while also
simultaneously moshi hoke was an advisor
on celsius years prior so things like
that so so getting a letter like that
that hyper fixates on one tiny thing to
try and i think strong arm me and
intimidate me into not speaking
it does feel good to be right but like i
said double edged sword because being
right means a bad thing for a great deal
of people
well said and i will link his youtube
channel below the point i'm trying to
make is that celsius didn't just have
problems in the immediate term like some
people think they did rather it seems
that they had every imaginable problem
from incompetent management to the fact
it seemed like a bloated company it also
is not clear that they were ever making
enough yield to pay back their investors
and maybe worst of all they would
publicly put on a front that
everything's fine while secretly uh
trying to hide the fact that they were
what looks like seconds away from
insolvency even a day before freezing
withdrawals their twitter account was
bragging about how quick and easy it is
to swap coins with them they say it
takes less time than it took to write
this tweet and this to me
is unforgivable
they know that they're about to go under
and they're trying to bring new
investors in right that is so
disgusting not only that it also looks
like alex mashinsky was pretending to be
sick only two days before
everything went under he said that he
lost his voice and was unable to attend
an ama and said he had to reschedule it
and honestly all indications point to
the fact they knew what was going on and
chose to hide this fact from their
customers who they knew were going to
get screwed because remember that
customers were not depositing they were
loaning to celsius this was an unsecured
loan meaning that when everything goes
belly up well too bad you're going to be
the last one to get paid as one of the
you know
regular retail investors on the other
hand a lot of the loans that celsius did
have from other big companies like
tether who they reportedly borrowed a
billion dollars from these were
collateralized loans so tether boasted
the other day that they had no exposure
to celsius's collapse and just
liquidated them it's also worth noting
that tether is a massive shareholder of
celsius go figure so once again the big
guys get out fine and the little guy
gets squashed and so it's at this point
that we have to say celsius looks pretty
much unsolvent especially if they got
liquidated for almost a billion dollars
they've lost money on badger dow on
steakhound they're losing money
everywhere and everyone wants their
money back at the same time now i know
things are getting heavy as i said
celsius looks insolvent from top to
bottom and there's been talk of them
trying to find some way to sort this all
out but i find it very ironic who they
turn to in their time of need this fake
bank that sees the big banks as bad guys
you know who they turn to when they're
finally admit that they screwed up
they turned to citigroup which is
a bank that's right ladies and gentlemen
can we all
just appreciate this fact that this fake
bank which was claiming to you know be
saving the people is now turning to a
real bank in their time of crisis you
just can't make this stuff up and that
maybe is the only funny part of this
whole story because i do have to say
there is some bad news which is that
alex mashinsky looks like he's walking
away with um let me uh check here
millions of dollars how is that possible
well because of celsius token the crypto
token they built around their company
also known as sell when it started it
really didn't do much there was no real
customer demand but through some clever
manipulation and incentives alex managed
to get himself some real demand for this
token that pretty much has no reason to
exist to understand how that's possible
you have to start by knowing that alex
mashinsky was just sort of given a lot
of these tokens to start obviously he's
the largest individual owner of cell but
he can sell them whenever he wants to
and of course the problem is why would
you buy this token that he automatically
has a bunch of money in if it's not like
going to give you a share in the profit
of the company well they thought of a
brilliant way to sort of create demand
out of thin air so you know how you can
invest your crypto in celsius and earn a
yield right well it turns out that if
you'd simply accept your payment in sell
tokens instead of let's say your native
cryptocurrency you deposited you'd be
paid extra money extra interest which is
pretty ingenious because it makes people
start to get into your token but it
wasn't just that they did they also
added something called a loyalty program
where if you held a balance of their
native token you'd get extra rewards on
your interest with the platinum level
giving you 30 percent more on your
interest payments and if you think the
degeneracy stops there well of course
you're wrong because they go even
further the next layer they added onto
that is that you can actually stake your
celsius in their earning program as well
and earn interest on your interest with
bonus interest is everyone following
that that's the way celsius inflated
their coins value which frankly sort of
had no reason to exist except to give
their founder a way out of the token
himself and sell it he did alex
mashinsky it turns out was sort of
constantly selling this cell token and i
spoke to dirty bubble media about this
once again and here's what he said yeah
so alex's selling was kind of a focus of
a lot of my work there was a total lack
of transparency around it um i mean
celsius often would kind of tell their
their transparency on things but when it
came to these sales he he would admit
that he was selling some tokens but
would never give a specific amount so so
based just on the numbers that celsius
itself provided they have a list called
the top 500 hotel or list that they
would periodically update that was the
top 500 holders of this sell token um it
looked like there were several million
tokens that were sold by mission c over
a period of about a year what is the
rough us dollar um
kind of equivalent of that tens of
millions tens of millions so he's
walking away basically even more rich
than he was before and his users are
walking away
what seems like maybe bankrupt
uh very possibly yes
wow that's heartbreaking when i later
went to the insider i had been talking
to at celsius and asked them what they
thought about this whole situation they
told me sort of a similar sentiment they
said two words
it's over so even though i don't like to
give bad news on this channel despite
what everyone thinks probably
i do have to agree i think celsius's
time as a fake bank larping as robin
hood is coming to an end
ironically they ended up screwing
regular people way worse than the real
banks ever will and it's become a huge
cautionary tale to not just listen to
people because they're saying what you
want to hear they told people that
financial freedom was just an investment
away that they would do all the heavy
lifting and all you had to do was sit
back and unbank yourself by
banking yourself and unfortunately
that's just kind of where this story
ends i know it's a bit of a bummer today
guys thank you for watching
and i'll see you in the next one